this summer cities around the country
are facing a major shortage of
lifeguards it means up to half the
public pools in the u.s could face
cutbacks chris vancleve is in virginia
beach with a look at this crisis chris
good morning
good morning it's happening at beaches
2. as recently as 2019 you would see
stacks of applicants who wanted to spend
their summer up in a lifeguard tower
like this one now coast to coast cities
and counties are scrambling just to find
enough lifeguards to keep their beaches
and pools open
tanner zilch is an increasingly rare
find someone who wanted to be a summer
lifeguard i work with a lot of my
friends like i feel like the environment
is really a lot of fun but it's also
like an important job obviously
but from california we had a horrible
turnout for our lifeguard trout to
connecticut it's been challenging for
the past couple years the once coveted
summer job is suddenly out of style the
american lifeguard association warns a
third to nearly half of the nation's 300
thousand public pools are expected to be
impacted
prompting closures delayed openings and
reduced hours
how hard is it to find a lifeguard right
now it's extremely challenging jimmy
davis is the director of aquatics for
palm beach county florida they're short
about 30 percent of summer employees
we're not going to be able to conduct as
many swim lessons as we normally do and
that has a direct impact on the
community and could potentially affect
the number of drownings that we see in
our communities
down 15 percent of their ocean
lifeguards some county beaches are being
left unstaffed we provide a public
service to the community and it is
imperative that we're we are there and
worries beachgoers nationwide it's
actually a bit terrifying because for me
i'm a weak swimmer
superhero is my day job boulder colorado
launched this be a superhero campaign
trying to woo potential applicants
austin texas had only about one third of
the lifeguards needed so the city
increased the pay and added up to 1250
in bonuses
and in richmond virginia parks and rec
will even teach applicants the basics we
help you learn how to swim if you need
swimwear we'll help you get swimwear we
make sure that we have those tools and
those instruments in place so you can
better serve the community
so why is this happening well the
pandemic is certainly a factor
lifeguards require special
certifications and it can be a
low-paying job in a lot of places 10 to
15 dollars an hour so there are more
flexible better paying options for
people in this tight labor market the
backup had always been temporary foreign
workers and those visa programs are
backlogged tony
it's just crazy no one seems to be
working anymore chris uh appreciate it
and i do hope before you even use calls
and send you somewhere you can get into
that water behind you it's looking like
a nice morning in virginia